Child stars live unique lives that frequently
include tons of money. While there are plenty
of cautionary tales of kid actors who've
struggled with demons, there are others who
turned out just fine, like the following
ones who ended up with loads of cash.
You might only be aware of Kaley Cuoco from
her work on the wildly popular sitcom The
Big Bang Theory, but she's been kicking around
Hollywood since she was just seven years old.
Her first big breakout came in 2002 when she
played Bridget on the ABC sitcom 8 Simple Rules,
but it was her performance as Penny on Big Bang
that made her a supernova. And you don't star on
one of TV's most-watched shows for over a decade
without making some serious cash along the way.
Cuoco reportedly started out earning around
$45,000 per Big Bang episode. This number
increased as the show gained a bigger and
bigger audience. For the final two seasons,
she and her co-stars were all making $1 million
per episode. She also owns a percentage of the
show's equity, allowing her to generate even
more income on top of her base salary. All told,
Cuoco's net worth is reportedly more than $100
million. Considering that she's moved on to other
successful projects since Big Bang ended, it
seems like the sky's the limit for Kaley Cuoco.
Sean Astin has worn a lot of different
hats throughout his acting career.
He's probably best known for his turn in The Lord
of the Rings trilogy as Samwise Gamgee, Frodo's
stalwart traveling companion and a hero in his own
right. But you've probably seen him in plenty of
other things since then. Stranger Things, No Good
Nick, and Supergirl are just a few of the credits
he's racked up since leaving Middle-earth. He also
has an impressive number of voiceover credits.
Astin's first star turn came when he was only
13 years old when he played Mikey in the 1985
adventure flick The Goonies. He went on to find
plenty more success in the years to come in the
likes of such films as Rudy, 50 First Dates,
and many more. This versatility has paid off
in a big way, as his net worth is reported
to be around $30 million. We're betting
that number will only continue to grow as he
keeps busy with a wide variety of projects.
Hilary Duff's childhood role remains her most
iconic. That's no surprise, as Lizzie McGuire
paved the way for the many teen-centric Disney
Channel sitcoms that followed in its wake.
Without Lizzie, there would surely be no Wizards
of Waverly Place or That's So Raven. Lizzie
McGuire's success was thanks to many different
qualities, including its thoughtful writing
and directing style, but none of it would've
worked without Duff's charming lead performance.
Duff has gone on to leverage that
early success into a steady career,
as she's starred in the likes of
such movies as Cheaper by the Dozen
and A Cinderella Story. She's
also had a notable music career,
as she's notched some chart-topping singles and
sold millions of albums. On top of all that,
she's branched out into a number of different
fashion and lifestyle brands as she continues
to be a force in movies and TV. Her most recent
notable credit is surely Kelsey Peters, a book
editor on the TV Land series Younger. Overall, her
net worth is estimated to be around $25 million.
Unlike a lot of former child stars,
Reese Witherspoon didn't really have
one massive role that broke her into the public
consciousness. Instead, she worked steadily,
finding a lot of success as a teenager, then
capably handling things as she rose through the
ranks to genuine superstardom. Nowadays, you could
pretty easily argue that she's one of the most
bankable stars in the world, and her estimated
net worth of over $200 million reflects that.
Witherspoon's first major part came at the
age of 14, when she landed the lead in the
coming-of-age film The Man in the Moon. Then
she really hit the big time in the late 90s
and early 2000s with such hit movies as Cruel
Intentions, Election, and Legally Blonde. She's
also branched out to TV in a big way, with
Big Little Lies and Little Fires Everywhere.
Much of Witherspoon's recent success also stems
from her work behind the scenes, as she frequently
produces the projects she acts in, thereby giving
herself an enviable amount of quality control. She
sure seems poised to continue her domination over
the entertainment industry in the years to come.
Nowadays, Ron Howard is better known for his work
behind the camera. He won a Directing Oscar for
A Beautiful Mind, and he's helmed plenty of
other notable films like Apollo 13 and Solo:
A Star Wars Story. But he actually
got his start in Hollywood as a child
actor. He started performing when he was
just five years old, and when he was six,
he landed the breakout iconic role of Opie Taylor
on The Andy Griffith Show. He enjoyed further
acting success as a teenager and young adult,
thanks especially to the George Lucas-directed
American Graffiti and the nostalgia-heavy
sitcom Happy Days. Howard still appears
occasionally on screen, and he also delivered
some iconic voice work on Arrested Development.
"Hey, that's the name of the show."
Ultimately, Howard has garnered most of his
fame and fortune as a director and producer.
His net worth is estimated
to be around $200 million.
That's a truly whopping number, but
it's pretty much what you'd expect from
someone who's equally comfortable directing
historical dramas as the latest Star War.
Drew Barrymore's experiences as a child actor
are both legendary and infamous. She started
performing at a very early age, with her first
big role coming when she was only seven in the
massively successful E.T. the Extra-Terrestrial.
That movie turned her into an overnight sensation.
She continued to land big parts, but she also
fell into the deepest depths of Hollywood's
party culture before she was even a teenager.
She was introduced to drugs and alcohol at
the age most kids are busy learning long
division. When she was just 16 years old,
she wrote an autobiography called Little Girl
Lost that details her struggles with addiction.
Luckily, Barrymore was able to recover from that
trauma and go on to have a lengthy and vibrant
career. She's appeared in a number of films
alongside her good buddy Adam Sandler, headlined
the Charlie's Angels flicks, and now she's
hosting her own talk show. She also has her own
production company, and she's even tried her hand
at directing. She's had her ups and downs, but she
ultimately ended up doing quite well for herself,
as she has an estimated net worth of $125 million.
"Um, freaking out!"
Jodie Foster has been a major
player in Hollywood for decades,
so it can be easy to forget that
she got started at a very young age.
Indeed, she was only six years old when she first
appeared on screen. She made a big impression on
Martin Scorsese when she appeared in his
1974 film Alice Doesn't Live Here Anymore,
which led to her big break a couple of years later
in his iconic 1976 flick Taxi Driver. She nabbed
an Oscar nomination for that film at just 14
years old — a hard feat to top, you might assume.
But the indefatigable Foster climbed to an even
higher level of stardom in 1991, when she starred
as FBI trainee Clarice Starling in The Silence
of the Lambs and won the Oscar for Lead Actress.
At this particular peak of her fame, Foster
negotiated massive salaries for herself,
as she went on to make big bucks for the
likes of Contact, Panic Room, and Flightplan.
She still appears on screen occasionally, but she
seems to be focusing more on her work behind the
camera at this stage in her career. She's directed
a few films, as well as episodes of TV shows like
Orange is the New Black and Black Mirror. Her
net worth is estimated to be over $100 million,
and she has the extremely impressive
filmography to prove that she deserves it.
Christian Bale is one of the biggest stars
in Hollywood. His major breakthrough came
in his mid-20s when he starred in the 2000
attention-grabbing thriller American Psycho.
But he'd been bit by the Hollywood bug long before
his bloody turn as Patrick Bateman. His first
major role came when he was just 13 in the Steven
Spielberg-directed war drama Empire of the Sun.
Soon after, he went on to star in the likes of
Newsies and the 1994 version of Little Women.
Thus, it's no stretch to say that Bale
was already a major name in Hollywood
when he achieved true superstar status
with 2005's Batman Begins. Since then,
Bale has been a bonafide A-lister, appearing
in blockbusters and arthouse films alike.
He's developed a reputation for undergoing
massive physical transformations to look
the part for his various roles, and he's
received dozens of accolades along the way,
including an Oscar for 2010's The Fighter. He's
also negotiated some massive salaries over his
career, and he's still going strong. He has a
net worth estimated to be around $125 million,
and as he continues to land roles in more major
franchises, that number will surely only go up.
"Abracadabra."
It's easy to lose track of just how
massive some pop stars truly are,
so it can be difficult to understand exactly how
high Ariana Grande's perch at the very top of the
fame ladder really is. When she was just 15,
she hit the stage in the Broadway musical 13,
and she ended up dropping out of high
school to focus on her music career.
She went on to reach a truly massive audience
when she was cast in the Nickelodeon sitcom
Victorious and then went on to also star
in the spinoff Sam & Cat. Her success as an
actor is nothing to sneeze at, but her bread and
butter has very much turned out to be pop music,
as she's achieved stratospheric heights of
popularity while putting out chart-topping tunes.
Grande has been making bank for a while
now, reportedly earning somewhere between
$20 and $30 million per year at the height of her
fame, and those numbers only continue to grow.
She reportedly earned more than $70
million from June 2019 through June 2020,
an absolutely astounding figure
for someone in her mid-20s.
Grande's most recent albums and concert tours have
attracted even bigger crowds and ticket sales.
It will be interesting to see just how
long she can keep her winning streak alive.
Based on how she's been going so far, we don't
expect her to start slowing down any time soon.
It can be easy to forget just how
prolific Neil Patrick Harris truly is.
He's shown off a wide array of talents over
the years on both the big and small screens,
as well as on the Broadway stage. His
biggest claims to fame are probably
his TV roles, but theater fans can
certainly claim him as their own.
You don't get to host the Tony Awards four times
if you're not a Broadway superstar, after all.
As Harris has gone through a few career
reinventions, it can be easy to forget how
he started. He started acting as a teenager in
the late 80s, and he was 16 when he landed the
lead role on Doogie Howser, M.D. After that show
ended, he continued to act consistently throughout
the 90s, but it wasn't until 2005 when he returned
to the heights of superstardom as he took on the
role of the womanizing Barney Stinson on How
I Met Your Mother, which ended up earning him
four Emmy nominations. Considering his charisma,
talent, and general likeability, we expect that
Harris will continue to remain relevant for
the foreseeable future. He's certainly done
well so far, as he has an estimated net worth
of around $50 million. Nice work, Doogie!
"It's gonna be legendary!"
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.